as someone who specializes in testing
and automation
there is something that really bugs me
when most developers i meet talk about
software testing
they only think about unit testing
in fact many people simply use the term
unit testing to refer to all testing
there's more to software testing than
writing tests
for methods and functions
unfortunately i see this misconception
fairly prevalently within the python
community
ever since
the python software foundation has
teamed up with jetbrains to conduct the
annual python developer survey
the survey asks many questions about who
python developers are
and what kinds of work they do
every year they include questions about
test frameworks
the first time i took the survey was in
2018 and i felt super excited to see a
question about testing
here are the results from that year's
survey
i was delighted to see pi test at the
top of the list
but then
my heart sank
when i read the result description
they called all the frameworks unit
testing frameworks
so sad
frameworks like pi test can be used for
more than unit testing
they can be used for testing web apps
mobile apps and rest apis as well
sadly that wasn't just a one-time fluke
the 2020 survey used the same naming
clearly the notion that unit testing
is preeminent is pervasive
i want to make it abundantly clear that
there is a difference between testing
code and testing features
code is the text in which software is
implemented
it contains the logic for execution
in python code has scripts
functions and classes
test classes that cover code explicitly
are called
white box tests because they have direct
access to the code's callables
the tests check
is the code written to do the expected
things
will this function return a proper
result
well that method update that object as
it should
whitebox tests may be unit tests if they
cover individual pieces of functionality
or they may be subcutaneous
if they test workflows through the code
features on the other hand are behaviors
of built products
features enable callers to do something
they are all the things a non-engineer
could do with your software product
for example a web app could have
features for entering profile
information
searching for records and uploading
files
features are implemented using code
but they themselves are not code
test cases that cover features are
called black box tests because they do
not have direct access to the code
instead
they exercise features like a regular
user or caller
the test check does the product meet its
requirements
black box tests may be called
integration or end-to-end tests because
they make sure all the pieces of a
software product come together to
produce the correct behavior
i could talk all day about different
kinds of testing but in this talk we'll
focus on web ui testing
web ui testing is black box testing of a
web app through a browser
its purpose is to verify that a web app
works the way a user would expect
to that end it is a type of feature
testing because tests it tests the app
like a user
it also is an
end test because all parts
of the web app
from the front end pages in the browser
to the service calls to the backend and
even to the databases for storing data
are all exercised together as one system
anyone can do web ui testing by loading
pages in a browser
but test automation makes execution
faster and more frequent
unfortunately though web ui testing is
expensive
environments have many parts set up for
testing
and web ui tests frequently require
multiple steps
it's impossible to test every behavior
of a web app
therefore
focus on the highest return on
investment
write unit and integration tests to
cover low level code and calls
write web ui tests for the most
important behaviors
and watch out for things like race
conditions
data collisions
and changing pages
when designing your test steps
it's no lie that web ui testing can be
hard
today let's try to make that easy
let's look at an example web ui test
together
the test case is a basic search test for
duckduckgo
a popular search engine
duckduckgo is available worldwide
its ui is simple
and everyone intuitively knows how to
use a search engine
step one in our test is to navigate to
the duckduckgo homepage at
duckduckgo.com
if you can't find it
i guess you can always google it
step two is to enter a search phrase
into the search bar
this should trigger a results page to
load
step three is to verify the query on the
results page
the phrase we ensured on the search page
should appear in the search bar on the
results page
step four is to verify that the search
phrase also appears in the page title
sometimes tests need to check multiple
things to make sure a feature is
behaving correctly
the final step is probably the most
important
the test should verify that each answer
on the results page somehow relates to
the search phrase
the search phrase could appear in the
title
the link or the description for each
returned item
we could write this test case and its
steps in gherkin's given when then
format for clarity
notice how this follows the arrange act
assert pattern
given an initial state
when actions are taken
then verify the outcomes
even though this web ui test is fairly
basic
it still holds a lot of value
because in only five lines
it determines if search is working
or completely broken
we could run this test manually
but we could also automate it using
python
automation enables us to run tests
faster and more frequently
it's incredibly valuable to run
automated tests
continuously going to show you how to
build a web ui test automation project
to automate our duckduckgo test using
some of the most popular tools and
patterns in the industry
as we build this solution together i
want you to keep in mind at all times
that test automation
is software development
full stop
when we automate tests we need to bring
the same care and attention to our code
as we would for any other project
we should follow good practices like
keeping our code in a source code
management tool like git
and also doing things like code reviews
test automation is a product
and continuous integration is its
production environment
test automation development is software
development
let's sketch out how we would develop
our test project
for our programming language we will use
python of course
for our core test framework we will use
pi test
if you recall for the python developer
survey results that i showed a few
slides before
pi test is the most popular python test
framework
for handling interactions with the ui
we will use the page object model
and finally for handling web browser
automation
we will use selenium webdriver
and we'll mention alternatives later in
this talk
so how do all these pieces fit together
pi test we'll call page objects
which in turn will call selenium
webdriver bindings in python
that connect to
either a local webdriver executable
process or a remote service like
selenium grid
to connect to a live browser session
and
wonderfully enough selenium webdriver
supports all the major browsers
so let's put those test steps for
duckduckgo searching into pi test
pi test is what we call a core test
framework
it is pythonic and powerful
tests are written as functions instead
of classes as they would be in unit test
on this slide i copied a screenshot from
the pi test.org homepage to show a pi
test test case example
here the ink function takes in a number
and adds one to it the test answer test
case calls the ink function
and makes an assertion on its result
in this case the test would fail because
ink of 3 should be 4
not 5.
in this talk i'm not going to teach how
to use pi test
but i will show it in code examples
if you want to learn more about pi test
check out the docs at pi test dot org
or pick up either of these two excellent
books
python testing with pi test by brian
ochen
and pi test quick start guide by bruno
oliviero
pi test is not part of python standard
library
so we need to pip install pi test to get
it
when developing web ui tests you can
choose to put the tests in the same
project as the web app they cover or you
can create a separate project
exclusively for test automation
either way for a python project it is
conventional to put all tests in a
subdirectory named tests
inside the tests folder add a module
named test underscore search
dot
with the function shown here
i like to start with test function stubs
that have the test case steps written in
comments
as i implement each step in python
i'll leave the original comment in place
for documentation
plain language descriptions for each
test case can be quite helpful when
re-reading test code in the future
to implement these steps we need
selenium webdriver for sending web ui
commands like clicking and scraping
from the test automation to a real live
browser
webdriver can handle every type of web
ui interaction you can imagine
if a user can do it then so can
webdriver
the webdriver api is enormous
i'll admit to you that i don't even know
it all
whenever i want to look up how to do
something
i check the docs online
they're very helpful and thorough for
python
the selenium webdriver package for
python is named selenium
to install it run pip install selenium
when running tests from a local machine
selenium webdriver also needs a
webdriver executable for the target
browser
in this talk we will use chrome so we
need to install chromedriver on our
local machine
and also add it to the system path
chromedriver acts as a proxy between
test automation and the browser
each browser type will have a different
webdriver executable
for example
firefox uses geckodriver
every test case needs its own browser
instance and therefore its own selenium
webdriver object
in a file named conf test.py
create a pi test fixture named
browser
the name of this file is important
because pi test uses it to find fixtures
like this one
inside the fixture
construct a new webdriver instance using
a statement like this
b equals selenium
selenium.webdriver.chrome
this line will construct the webdriver
object for the chrome browser
it will automatically start a chrome
driver process too
that's why your webdriver executables
like chrome must be on the system path
if desired you could construct
webdrivers for other browsers here
next set an implicit weight of 10
seconds for the webdriver
whenever this webdriver will try to
fetch web elements from a page
it will wait up to 10 seconds for the
element to appear before giving up and
raising an exception
if you do not provide an explicit weight
then tests will be susceptible to race
conditions
in which automation will try to access
elements before the browser can render
them on the page
implicit weights keep tests safe
other web apps might need more than 10
seconds if they take more time to load
next make the fixture return the
webdriver object with yield b
this return will inject the webdriver
object into any test case that calls
this fixture
finally quit the browser as the final
part of the fixture
pi test will run anything in a fixture
after a yield statement
as cleanup after a test case is finished
even if the test case fails
quitting the web driver will close the
window and quit the browser instance
always quit
or else your machine might
leave zombie processes running in the
background
as a recommended practice tests should
not call selenium webdriver directly
instead they should use page objects to
model the pages under test
a page object has locators for finding
elements on the page
as well as interaction methods that send
commands to located elements
for example a login page object could
have locators for user names and
passwords
and a method for logging in
our test needs two pages
a duckduckgo search page with methods
for load and search
and a duckduckgo results page
for getting the query
title
and result links
let's look at the search page
i like to put page objects in a package
outside the tests folder
so that they can be easily imported into
test modules
i also like to put each page object in
its own python module such as one named
search dot py
the page object should be a class with
an intuitive name
it should have variables for urls if
appropriate
and locators should be stored as tuples
with locator type and query
here the search input locator
can be located using a name locator with
the name q
the class's dunder and knit method
should take in a reference to the
webdriver object which it will receive
from the test case function
the interaction methods here then call
the webdriver to do the needful
the load method loads the duckduckgo
homepage using the url
and the search method locates the search
input
element and enters a phrase into it
you can see webdriver methods like get
bind element and send keys
method names like load and search
better describe the actual interaction
being done here
so you might be wondering
how do we know that the search input
element could be located by the name q
the easiest way to come up with locators
is to use a tool like chrome dev tools
to inspect the source code for the page
under test
locators can use ids
input names class names
css selectors
department or xpaths to identify
elements
i recommend using the simplest locator
possible that uniquely identifies the
target element
on the duckduckgo homepage the search
input element has an attribute named
name with a value of q
writing good locators could
easily be its own talk
if you want to learn more about it take
my free course on test automation
university entitled web element locator
strategies
now
we have all the pieces in place to
automate our test case
revisit the original test function
and add browser as its argument
pi test will match this name against the
fixture we wrote named browser
and then call it to initialize the
webdriver object
using the webdriver object we can
construct page objects
we did not show the code for result page
but it would be similar to the code for
the search page
the first step calls search page dot
load to load the
go home page in the browser
the second step performs a search for
the phrase panda
the third step verifies that the results
page's search input value is correct and
that it matches the query
the fourth step then verifies that the
search phrase is in the title
and the final step makes sure that the
search phrase appears in each result
link title
notice how it uses a for loop to look to
iterate over every single title returned
for the links
and it also formats all titles to lower
case when performing its assertion
and that's our test fully automated in
python
pi test page objects and selenium all
come together beautifully
and the test itself
thanks to our page objects
is quite readable
that's a lot of information in a short
amount of time
there's way more to learn about web ui
testing than i could possibly cover in
half an hour if you want to learn more
check out these free courses from test
automation university
tau test automation university is an
incredibly wonderful platform for
learning all about testing and
automation
i hope these courses can help you become
a python test automation champion in no
time
before i close i want to mention one
more thing
selenium is not the only tool out there
for interacting with browsers
recently a new tool hit the scene
playwrights
playwright syntax feels more concise and
modern than webdriver's api
it also provides features like automatic
weighting
more resilient element selectors and
isolated browser contexts
things that selenium webdriver doesn't
provide
like selenium playwright has bindings in
multiple languages including python
i haven't yet used playwright myself but
i've heard that it performs a little
faster than selenium
if you automate your tests using page
objects
then theoretically you could easily swap
selenium calls with playwright calls
the only downside with playwright right
now is it does not have a tool for
scaling out execution like selenium grid
nevertheless i believe playwright will
be a major contender against selenium
webdriver in coming years
it'll be fun to watch it happen
so
this concludes my talk on web ui testing
thank you very much for joining and
thank you especially to the organizers
of pycon taiwan for inviting me to speak
unfortunately i'm unable to take live
questions but if you have any questions
feel free to contact me through my blog
or through twitter
again my name is andy knight and i'm the
automation panda i hope to see you all
around the python community and i hope
to revisit taiwan